i found another one if donald trump does
lose this election it'll be because of
people like katie paris
she's one of what he calls the suburban
women
he's what she calls for this generation
and the next
wrong for america so many of us are moms
and
we see the country through the eyes of
our children who
in whom we're trying to instill good
values of respect for one another
kindness and how you treat people every
day and we don't see that reflected
by the president of the united states we
cannot even have him on tv if our
children
are in the room suburban women will you
please like me yet the president has
been pleading for support
the polls say it's done more harm than
good when he refers
to women who live in the suburbs as
housewives like we're some 1950s i mean
figment of his imagination it just
further shows that complete
disconnection
like not that much the group she founded
red
wine and blue has friends among those
who voted for
trump in 2016 but now see things
differently
if this one over here my nine-year-old
behaved how he behaves
he would probably be expelled from
school i mean he's just a bully he makes
fun of people
talks down to them you know racism the
george floyd thing happened
pretty much right in secession with the
pandemic and that's kind of was my
emotional breaking point
um just realizing how dangerous trump
being in office was
realizing that like all of our kids are
not safe in the world that you know four
years ago we elected to build
if when joe biden wins this election
it'll be because of suburban women
this really gives you a sense like you
know the trump pen is next to the nope
this is where this election is being
fought and where they feel trump's use
of phrases like
housewives is off target it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of
who we are as a society right in terms
of the role women play in the workforce
that the role women play in the
communities in terms of being key
opinion leaders quite honestly and key
decision makers in terms of being the
ones that are most active that's just my
house i'm just going to point out
nor has never been a trump fan in groups
like hers
his former supporters are very welcome
they have seen the reality of who this
person really is um you know the saying
when someone shows you who they are
believe them i think they're believing
it now that was a wake-up call for a lot
of women
the polls suggest there'll be a
record-breaking gender gap in this
election
and that women will win it for biden
the campaign signs share the lawns with
halloween in suburbia
right now both will soon be gone how
long has this name left
in american politics greg milam sky news
cleveland in ohio